Emily Blunt appears in Christopher
Nolan's latest epic as Catherine
Oppenheimer and apparently that'll be
her last role for the next year blunt
has two daughters seven-year-old Violet
and nine-year-old Hazel and as she
revealed in conversation with Bruce
bossy she wants to enjoy their childhood
more fully this year I'm not working I
worked quite a bit last year and my
oldest baby is nine and I just feel like
there are cornerstones to their day that
are so important when they're little she
continued it's when you wake me up will
you take me to school will you pick me
up will you put me to bed right
and I just need to be there for all of
them ultimately blunt said she feels
guilty about potentially missing her
daughter's childhoods and she thinks
that's common for moms she added on the
podcast
you just prone to feeling bad for God
forbid wanting something outside of
being a mother